hope has been the only thing fans of
showtime's dexter have had to hold on to
since the series ended in 2013.
after eight seasons when all is said and
done dexter morgan doesn't die
and he isn't caught for the vigilante
murders he's committed the serial killer
who only kills other killers instead
leaves everything behind and exiles
himself from the world and what made for
one of the most frustrating tv finales
of all time
some people think dexter might be
capable of living happily ever after and
something
no he needs to be punished but yet we
don't really
do either of those the ending wasn't as
conclusive as dexter's demise would have
been but it did provide a golden shimmer
of hope that dexter's story might not be
over
now some huge news is broken that takes
that sliver of hope a step
or several steps further don't get your
hopes up would be an easy response to
any news that claims michael c
hall's serial killer next door might be
appearing on the screen once again
we've seen dexter-related hopes squashed
before and nobody wants to see this
fandom hurt again
we were promised a prequel and we got an
animated web series in 2009
we were slammed with rumors of spin-offs
that never happened after a series of
interviews with the dexter actor talking
about how he wouldn't mind reprising the
role for a season 9 fans latched on to
the words as a real possibility
then showtime announced in 2019 that no
active talks about a 9th season were
taking place
fans hopes were crushed for a while
anyway everything changed on october
14th
2020 when showtime announced that all of
our dexter dreams are finally going to
come true
surprise motherfu according to the
hollywood reporter showtime is bringing
dexter back for a limited series
the series isn't set to be an ongoing
thing as of right now it'll run for a
total of 10 episodes and bring hall back
as the world's favorite fictional serial
killer even better the production is
scheduled to begin next year so
it's not only talk by every indication
this is really happening
the story is set to take place after the
series finale with dexter living a
solitary existence as a lumberjack type
and a new life he's crafted for himself
after faking his death at the end of
season eight
despite dexter's early retirement from
his career of killing there's sure to be
a lot of murderous happenings since it's
a huge part of the character's identity
in the vein of other fake their own
death stories there's a good chance that
the upcoming limited series will see
dexter haunted by the ghosts of his past
it's even possible that dexter will meet
his end at the hands of the state
you know for all those murders he's
committed for what it's worth that's the
ending that clyde phillips co-producer
and original showrunner on the series
had in mind for dexter from the very
beginning
how would you like to see dexter end i
don't know
it'd be cool if he if he if he's going
to die he should die
funny the dexter limited series is
bringing back phillips as a showrunner
as well so maybe he'll have the chance
to actually make good on his original
vision
phillips ran the writer's room until
2009 and during his time on the show
dexter scooped up several emmy award and
writer's guild award nominations
his inclusion for this new 10 part
sequel series is welcome news indeed
it's not every day that a series as well
known and is ultimately tragic as dexter
gets a second chance
for anyone who hasn't seen dexter news
of this limited series revival would be
like
in 2026 seven years after game of
thrones ended hbo making the
announcement that 10 more episodes are
coming down the pipe
have you shot your final scenes yet and
are you happy with how
things ended
naturally dexter fans are pretty much
freaking out about this one-off
extension project as it might offer a
better ending than the originals
on the flip side though some are
freaking out for a very different reason
they've been so badly burned by dexter's
ending that they don't want anything to
do with the limited series
i'm absolutely expecting mixed reactions
from the fans
some people will like it and i know some
people hate it one fan wrote on twitter
from the way it ended i honestly don't
want any more please
replying to that tweet another user
wrote if you didn't like the end of the
show
then give this season a chance it's been
so long that they have a fresh idea for
a story that could redeem the ending it
got and dexter won't be remembered
having a bad ending
one twitter user didn't mince words and
sharing their excitement upon hearing
news of the limited series writing
yes that ending was the worst i hope
they fix that nonsense
elsewhere a dexter fan proposed that the
minds behind the dexter limited series
should not only quote
fix that trash ending but also tap into
the spirit of earlier seasons of the
show
they said of the series coming back for
10 more episodes the first four seasons
of dexter was riveting well written and
superbly acted television
elsewhere another twitter user agreed
that dexter is on the whole equality
show but that they're wary of it coming
back
and possibly ending in an even worse way
than it did initially
they tweeted you'd think i hate dexter
but i really really loved it
i'm just salty about the last season and
really don't want it ruined more
at this stage it's impossible to predict
what the dexter limited series will look
and feel like
many are choosing to be optimistic about
what's in store while others are taking
caution
whatever side of the fence you sit on
strap in for what's bound to be an
interesting ride when dexter returns
sometime in 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one